[Music]
foreign
obviously cyber security is really
important for all financial institutions
it is more than just security itself it
is part of a broader kind of mission of
maintaining trust with with the clients
and the financial services industry we
look at Google as a critical partner
that will help us bring quite a bit of
advantage in the fight that we have
against
those type of threats that we deal with
that continue to expand on a regular
basis
we are leveraging Chronicle to collect
all the Telemetry that we have across
the board from all the sources of data
and we have a ton we need to be able to
scale and Google offers us that level of
scale leveraging the Google cloud with
Chronicle but Chronicle also is the
foundation of a bigger ecosystem that we
like when it comes to how we think of
advanced data analytics and how to
enable us to be proactive
we have advanced capabilities around
threat intelligence that are highly
integrated into the chronicle platform
we like the orchestration capabilities
that enable us to enrich the data
provide additional context to it so our
security operations center and analysts
are able to prioritize that work be able
to respond to it with the attention that
it needs
the acquisition of Mandy and I thought
was was an outstanding move by Google
the knowledge of Andy and bring in
because they are involved in so many
incidents and and the incident response
processes globally brings that Dimension
from not only from a people perspective
but adding that to the product on a
regular basis and building that
continuous loop feedback is critical to
allow us to stay ahead we've seen
advances in autonomous driving we've
seen advances in in aviation where
pretty much fairly Advanced tasks are
being handled by computers I think we
can do the same in cyber security we can
have self-healing concepts by leveraging
Ai and machine learning many of these
capabilities to help us make decisions
real time and allow us to have more of
that situational variability and remove
the predictability factor that we have
currently in our static approaches to
start cyber security